hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today I am going to
explain a 2018 Russian science fiction
and action movie called a rough draft
which follows the story of a talented
video game developer who finds himself
erased from his closest People's
memories and must Embrace a new life as
an interdimensional Customs officer a
young man named kiril maximoff gets
caught by the police inside their car
after a bar fight luckily the police let
him go he goes home with a route
calculated from his phone meanwhile his
ex-girlfriend Anna is talking to another
man Anton in a car she now joins a new
Corporation causing her to not be able
to go abroad for a while she goes home
to find herself surprised by kiril and
his best friend kotia who records the
event kiril offers her a luxurious gift
but he misremembered her birthday she
drives him off and tells him to move on
with his life Carill and kochia go to
their company party to celebrate kiril's
new video game development girls flirt
with him and bosses Praise Him however
he still thinks about his failed
surprise with Anna he tells kocha he
needs to walk his dog back home so
kotija drives him home
surprisingly his dog does not remember
him a young lady seems to occupy his
home and owns his dog replacing all his
furniture and wall decorations kirell
thinks someone has pulled an elaborate
prank on him so he goes to cochia's
place they plan to go to the Civil
office tomorrow to take care of his
property the next day he finds that his
identity has been erased from all legal
institutions making him lose all his
possessions he goes to his office to
find his co-workers no longer
recognizing him completely forgetting
last night's party his boss does not
even want to pay him he thinks kochia
has been pulling pranks on him but he
does not remember him as well he goes to
his parents for the same response out of
desperation he visits his old apartment
again and asks for an explanation the
young woman Renata motions him to stab
her he is shocked then tries to run away
but is pinned down Carill is transported
back to when he is detained in the
police car
he gets a new route arriving at an
abandoned Clock Tower and falls asleep
the next day he finds the tower has been
dramatically transformed it has many
doors each leading to completely
different dimensions his new main
Dimension now is a steampunk version of
Moscow Renata healthy and not injured
appears to tell in his new position or
functional as a customs officer she says
she will be back and expect him to learn
and do his job well Curel then calls
kocha and offers him to come to his
place while balancing his new life as a
customs officer his friend is fascinated
by kiril's ability to produce anything
he desires just by thinking about it
then kiril receives Anna and Anton who
want to travel between realities they
want to travel to the steampunk
Dimension Kim Jim Carell and kochia
follow suit visiting a place called
White Rose there they encounter a deadly
Matryoshka Droid kiril battles the Droid
while kokia records it on his phone
kirell turns out to be invincible and is
skilled at martial arts effectively
disabling the Droid after that they
observe blood dripping from upstairs
upstairs they find Rosa another
functional being wounded and bloodied
she lives in the White Rose and is
responsible for the steampunk Dimension
she runs the place treats kirill's
wounds and explains to him that he is
invincible and near Immortal to carel's
surprise Anton comes to White Rose with
Anna the following day kiril unlocks a
new door to the beach he receives visits
from the inspectors and Renata who gives
him a leash the leash will hurt him if
he stays away more than 15 kilometers
from his Tower she tells him that
everyone has their functions in this
world and tonight Rosa will throw a
party for him to discover his function
denying the 15 kilometers limit imposed
on him Carill takes the subway to visit
his parents even though they do not know
him he almost passes out along the trip
and is helped by strangers he brings his
mother's favorite flowers and quickly
charms his parents earning him a place
to stay at dinner the next day he meets
Anton and Anna again who now want to go
to the beach
he questions Anton about his status and
whether he has been having an affair
Anton does not confirm any of the claims
on another chance kiril musters up the
courage to ask Anna on dates and they
grow closer he takes her to his
functional welcoming party the ladies
Renata and Rosa quickly separate them
and tell Anna that functionals cannot
have kids they plan to drive Anna away
from kiril because she is a distraction
from his job meanwhile kiril meets Felix
while playing billiard who tells him
that they are monitored by arkhan a
utopian Dimension and people known as
the curators kiril expresses that he
wants to break free from his functional
duties but Felix warns him that would
cause his identity to be erased even
having this conversation with him is
dangerous the ladies Drive Anna away
from the party then she heads home
despite being chased she begs kiril to
let her go then she takes a taxi
undenounced to her Renata and Rosa have
planned for her abduction meanwhile
inspector Irina visits kiril and
explains that the last known portal to
arkhan was in the Soviet Union people in
Arkansas seem to control everything they
make this Earth a rough draft so that
their world can be a perfect final draft
of the world Irina wants kiril to work
hard on reopening the arkhan portal even
though he is unsure of it while hearing
all this kiril receives a text from Anna
realizing she is abducted he chases
after her but is 15 kilometers limit
forbids him he falls unconscious on the
road Anton turns out to be functional
too he learns about Anna's disappearance
while he is transporting other
functionals dead bodies meanwhile kiril
wakes up in a reality where kami's in
Gulag Prevail he meets the world's
Customs officer vasilisa she gives him a
knife and openly flirts with him while
seeing basilisa doing her job he sees a
prisoner resembling Anna and stages a
commotion to escape with her he faces
Vasa Lisa and wins letting her get
dragged by the crowd but the curator who
turns out to be cocha finds him back in
his Tower he is too powerful for kiril
so he easily overcomes him and sets his
limit to 15 meters refusing to give up
saving Anna kiril brings her to the
beach via a portal where she breaks out
off his leash and refutes his limits but
the process badly injures her he puts
her on his bed then leads to open a
portal to arkhan he successfully does it
and arrives in the utopian world of
arkhan he meets his Customs officer
counterpart who warmly welcomes him and
shows him around he explains that arkhan
is the perfect world where everything
was tested beforehand on kiril's Earth
the rough draft World in arkhan peace
prevails and there are no life-changing
historical Wars however kiril notices
people leaving his place
he wants to leave too but the officer
forbids him he realizes he has been
pinned down by people and even droids
they fire at him but his Invincible body
can withstand the injuries he swims to
the river ducking the droid's attacks
and resurfaces from the sewer Hull he
fights his way back to the portal so he
can come home to his Tower however
Renata already awaits him at the tower
knowing that he hides Anna he demands
she give Anna's location so the two
battle intensely kiril knows Renata is
no longer human so she stabs her with
his knife the tower collapses on top of
them burying both of them kiril survives
the attack desperately rebuilding doors
so he can access portals to find Anna
the curator finds him but now with no
intention of hurting him he welcomes him
and they both leave the place for other
Adventures meanwhile as firefighters
arrive at the collapsed Tower Renata's
body twitches a little
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching